مع طاقم الفيلم الآن
تعمل في مطار يصل إلى 100 ميل
من هنا إلى كييف ما يزيد قليلاً عن عشرين
كيلومترات الآن هذا المطار
يسيطر عليها الروس
القوات المحمولة جوا
انظر إلى الوضع هنا
السفر ليس آمنًا جدًا لأن
أن هناك الكثير من المواد غير المنفجرة على الأرض
ذخيرة المدفعية الأوكرانية
قصفت المطار ، انظر
دخلوا ما تبقى منه في الحظيرة
قتلت من وراء ظهري زوجتي
المعدات الأوكرانية التي تخلوا عنها
هنا وكذلك سقطت قذائف أوكرانية
في الحظيرة حيث تم تخزين أكبرها
طائرات النقل في العالم
An-225 Mriya
ترجم إلى الروسية الحلم بذلك
أصابته قذائف مدفعية أوكرانية
لم تعد الطائرة تحترق ماريا
المقدمة من قبل المظليين الروس والأول
المساعدة الطبية للجرحى
تم علاج الجروح من قبل الجيش الأوكراني
تطبيق ضمادات عاصبة واحدة من
الجرحى الضباط الطبيب العسكري الروسي
أجرى استخراجًا ناجحًا
شظايا وضعت كل الأسلحة
الجنود الأوكرانيون الذين رفضوا القتال
العودة إلى المنزل في أقرب وقت ممكن
إيرينا كوكسين الذي ديمتري كاتشورين نيكيتا
قناة سيفاستيانوف الأولى